Sometimes the world feels boring.
We've visited all the remote islands,
conquered the Arctic and penetrated the deepest jungles,
but there is still one place to explore.
It's a wet and deadly desert inhabited by mysterious creatures
living in total darkness.
The deep sea that's dive down.
When we look at the sheer scale of the Earth's oceans,
it's hard to believe that less than 2% of all biomass on earth lives here
and of that small percentage around 90% is located close to the
surface in the first 200 meters.
This is where we begin our journey.
Headlight can still penetrate the water,
which allows photo synthesis to occur phytoplankton, trillions,
and trillions of single celled,
algae and bacteria make up the foundation of the ocean's ecosystem.
And they're consumed by bigger plankton who are consumed by other species.
The sea floor at this depth is akin to the Amazon rainforest and is often
covered with coral reefs, algae, and other seed plants.
These are home to a plethora of sea animals so far we've focused most of our
attention on this comparatively pleasant environment where we fish swim,
pollute and do science. So let's dive deeper,
moving from familiar coastal waters into deeper, more remote waters.
We eventually reached the edge of the continental shelf,
where we're confronted with the continental slope,
the long descent down to the deep sea with every additional meter
of water light fades drastically,
which means there are basically no more plants and the seemingly steep
continental slope begins to remind us of the surface of the moon,
looking out where faced by what seems to be endless open water.
Let's leave the slope behind us and enter. What's known as the Twilight zone,
the portal to the deep sea. As we sink down further,
the water pressure rises to deadly levels.
The deepest scuba dive ever came in at 332 meters.
At that depth,
the pressure is like having 200 cars stacked on top of you yet.
We've only completed 3% of our journey while this region
seems pretty grim,
many fish and other animals actually spend at least half their lives down here
during the day.
It's a good place to rest and recover hidden from predators in the vast dark
waters at night,
they can travel more safely into shallower zones to feed in the food.
Rich surface waters in this transition zone between Twilight and
darkness light becomes a powerful tool.
Over 90% of the species indigenous to this deep environment,
use bioluminescence chemicals to create night.
They do set last camouflage against the very faint sunlight to send signals to
potential mates or to confuse and scare attackers,
or they use likes to hunt.
Another tool for survival in the dark is teamwork at around 700
meters. We encounter a colony of siphonophores.
They can be up to 50 meters in length,
but are only as wide as a broomstick to attract prey.
A colony creates a tragically beautiful bright blue or red light and
deploys.
A curtain of tentacles filled with toxic needles that kill anything that
comes to close.
But most species living down here have to rely on an unlikely resource
Marine,
snow white flaky stuff that constantly sinks from the surface to the
bottom of the ocean. It consists of dead plant or animal parts,
fecal matter shells, sand or dust,
even though this doesn't sound very tasty without this crucial resource life in
the deep sea woodstove it's in this area,
that the most fascinating battles between two unlikely enemies could happen.
Sperm, whales, Hunter, and attack giant square to the size of a house.
While the squid fight back ferociously, they probably don't stand a chance,
but they do leave permanent marks on their killer skin.
As we reach 1000 meters deeper than the tallest structure built by humans,
we need to be careful. This is the midnight zone,
a place of utter darkness,
a barely explored wet wasteland consisting of nothing but endless blank.
Open water at these deaths is harder for a human to take a swim than to
take a walk in space.
Finding food down here is really hard.
So life had to adapt and become extremely energy efficient,
like the 30 centimeter long vampire squid that floats through the water without
motion with long than slender catching arms extended they're covered
in tiny stiff has which brush food from the water.
This saves a lot of energy compared to activate catching food
for carnivorous fish.
It's much harder to find food since living prey is quite rare down here.
So the hunters have to get a perfect grip on their victim on first strike.
Otherwise it will escape into the dark many deep sea predators have
several sets of long and deadly teeth like the Viper fish,
which uses its long fangs to trap even large prey and swallow it.
Hold all the frill chalk with its impressive set of 300 teeth,
which are curved backwards to hook their victims in their mouths.
We sink further below the 3,800 Mark,
as deep as the grave Titanic.
We are now at abyssal depths here.
Life happens in slow motion.
Preserving every last bit of energy is crucial for survival.
Everything down here, hovers,
motionless or swims in a slow elegant fashion.
The only time the animals living in this sonar move fast is when they have to
escape danger,
like the Dumbo Octopod paddling with its airline fins or the Grenederes
fish with its slow eel like tail beets at 4,000
meters, we finally reached ground again.
The abyssal plane it's coveting grain,
modern rocks dusted with the remains of Marine snow,
which is consumed by animals like sea cucumbers,
shrimp [inaudible] and sea worms.
In some regions of the sea floor, small dark mineral deposits can be seen.
These are manganese nodules, deep sea corals,
and sponges use them to anchor themselves on the bottom of the sea. Though.
Life is sparse on the deep sea floor. Even down here,
there are oases in the rift valleys where tectonic plates are spitting
apart.
Magma heats up seawater and creates dump jets of water and minerals as hot as
400 degrees Celsius that form elaborate chimneys and towers.
Extremophile bacteria use the minerals to create organic substances that are the
basis for unique ecosystems. As we descend further,
we reach the deepest point of the abyssal painter at 6,000 meters.
For most of the C4. This is as deep as it gets,
but if we want to get to the deepest point of the oceans,
we're actually only halfway there let's enter the Hayden zone,
the underworld of the sea.
It consists of long narrow trenches that only make up around at the 0.2,
5% of the oceans and are among the most extreme environments on earth
only extremophiles exist down here like the Ethereum snail fish that
holds the record for the deepest living fish ever seen at around 8,000 meters.
We see spiky and sharp black rocks rush by as we sink down to more than 10,000,
it wasn't until we reached the final slope,
a trench inside the larger Mariana trench with gently sloping sides that
in frame of Valley, about 1.6 kilometers wide,
this is the deepest point.
The challenge of deep 11,000 meters below the surface
water pressure here is 1086 bar taking
a swim hair is like having to balance 1800 elephants on top of you.
But even here,
life has found a way to thrive next to sea cucumbers,
white light pink amphipods wiggle their way through the water.
Their size is astounding while they're shallow water cousins of media,
a few centimeters long,
the deep sea version can reach up to 30 centimeters and
there are other things floating elegantly through the water plastic bags that
were found by scientists in 2018.
Even the remotest place on earth is not safe from human influence.
There is nothing left to do now and our oxygen is running out.
So we begin our set.
[Inaudible].
After hours of traveling through dark nothingness,
we finally see a glimpse of light.
We arrive back at a calm surface.
The oceans are so deep. There is so much of them.
We owe it to ourselves and to our descendants to preserve them as well as we
can.
There are still so many wondrous things left to be discovered.
So you're all tingling now and want to go exploring why not start
off with some juicy science.
You can use our friends from brilliant as your springboard for a knowledge deep
dive. Brilliant is a website that helps you approach science in a practical way
through interactive courses and daily problems in maths science and computer
science. And instead of simply flooding you with information,
you get the tools you need to untangle complex topics by yourself.
It's hands-on learning instead of chalk and talk plunge in and get to the bottom
of courses about things like geometry waves and light gravitational physics,
and many more click the link in the description or visit brilliant.org/nutshell,
to sign up for free and learn more things than there are fish in the sea.
And there's an extra perk for Kurds because aren't viewers the first 688 people
to use the link, get 20% of that annual membership,
which lets you view all the daily problems in the archives and unlock every
course. Brilliant helps you end your day, a little smarter,
go ahead and take the plunge. Do you need more vitamin C?
We've also made an Epic poster featuring some of the most fascinating creatures
we encountered on our dive. It's much less work than an aquarium,
but just as soothing and pretty.